Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass so bisweilen eine digitale Sorglosigkeit an den Tag legst.
Das äh tue nicht nur ich, denn äh trotz Vorratsdatenspeicherung und NSA-Überwachung bewegen wir uns ja noch in diesem Netz. Statt äh mal auf die Straße zu gehen und irgendwie ein paar Sachen umzuwerfen oder so.
Keine Sorglosigkeit an den Tag legt Buch Netzpolitik der Zungenbrecher, der euch wöchentlich schwer über die Lippen kommt,
aber den ihr trotzdem äh vermisst, wenn ihr nicht in die Ohren kommt. Stimmt's Linus? So sieht's doch aus,
So ist es. Wir äh senden nach wie vor und äh unverblümt und wir müssen auch.
Ja, die, die, die Nachrichtenlage zwingt uns dazu. Ich wollte eigentlich ja mal äh ich habe gedacht, ach ja, vielleicht auch mal nicht,
Aber nein, aber nein. Aber nein, es es gibt wieder Neues zu berichten, aber ich muss erstmal, glaube ich, eine etwas, eine etwas peinliche, also, genau, zwei Sachen aus der letzten Sendung erzählen,
wir fangen an mit der Richtigstellung, ich hab während ich das ablaß von von dem Pat, was ich ja selbst was mit meiner eigenen Hand geschrieben wurde,
habe ich gedacht, hör mal, das war mir so gar nicht klar, dass der BND-Chef äh Schindler im BND-Ausschuss war. Aber,
ich habe da auch noch kurz so bin da noch drüber gestolpert, aber hab's dann seelenruhig erzählt. Es handelte sich um einen Copy Paste Fehler. Ich habe ja diese Sendung auf achtzig Disketten,
vorbereitet,
und ähm dabei halt irgendwie ein ein Fragment, ein ein kleines Fragment eines Presseartikels an die falsche Stelle kopiert, äh sodass irgendwie,
unter äh nichtöffentliche Sitzung eingerückt noch eine Äußerung von BND Chefstand.
Und bin dann dazu gekommen und habe behauptet der, wer dort gewesen ist, war ein Fehler und äh der ist,
ähm Anne Roth auch sofort aufgefallen, die mich darauf hingewiesen hat, der der ich sehr äh für diese Rückmeldung danke. Allen anderen ist er nicht aufgefallen, da kann man mal sehen, was wir hier für ein für einen Quatsch erzählen.
Oder was für Co-Moderatoren du hast.
In Wirklichkeit war nämlich der Tim da.
Ja, mir ist das natürlich dann auch nicht aufgefallen.
Und dann war ich ein bisschen ein bisschen erschüttert, dass ich dass sich niemand auf unseren Aufruf gemeldet hat, doch mal ein ein,
eine D-Mail zu verschicken.
Wirklich.
Ich meine, ja niemand, keine einzige Rückmeldung. Ich glaube, der der einzige äh,
Also auf, auf Twitter äh witterte man dann auch den den den Köder und sagte so, ey weißt du, seit drei Jahren rennt er rum und erzählt, wie Scheiße D-Mail ist und jetzt auf einmal soll sich D-Melzer bei dem melden.
Ist doch gekauft von den Illuminaten.
Gekauft. Ja, okay, tut mir leid, dann können wir eben da jetzt das nicht machen. Aber die die also so viele Witze, wie wir darüber gemacht haben, die Frage war ursprünglich mal ernst gemeint, aber jetzt ziehe ich sie zurück.
Tja.
Mach mich doch nicht lächerlich.
Also mit anderen Worten, das wird hier nichts mit äh Tinder für D-Mail. Da findet sich einfach keiner.
Da findet sich keiner. Da ist keiner. Ja, da da ist einfach noch nicht viral geworden.
Ja das der äh elektronischen Nachrichtensysteme.
Das elektronische Nachrichtendienst möchte man.
Oh ja. Oh Mann.
Ja, die Nachrichtendienste, die halten uns äh auch ähm.
Aber wer uns vor allem äh wach hält, das ist äh unsere Bundesregierung, die ja, wie wir das schon angedeutet haben.
Avancen hat, ne?
Ja, wir hatten, wir hatten es erwähnt, dass äh die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist so sicher wie die Rente oder oder wie äh könnte man das nennen? Ähm.
Es wurde ja schon vor einigen Wochen die Leitlinien veröffentlicht, die äh Heiko Maas dann der Stolz äh präsentierte als äh Ergebnis seines Kampfes gegen.
Ähm seines widerschwänzigen Kampfes, den er dann am Ende doch äh verloren hat, indem er klein beigegeben hat, indem er eingeknickt ist, indem er gezeigt hat, dass er im wahren Herzen eben doch Sozialdemokrat ist
und früher oder später,
ähm uns das Messer in den Rücken rahmt und ähm seitdem warteten alle auf das äh auf den Referentenentwurf,
der ereilte mich dann äh per E-Mail ähm von,
direkt aus dem BMJ erreichte mich eine E-Mail mit dem aktuellen Referentenentwurf so viel kann man verraten,
gefeiert in allen Medien, muss ich allerdings sagen, es war kein, sondern einfach die offizielle äh Zirkulation des Referentenentwurfes an die interessierten Verbände
aussehen, dass Netzpolitik ORG League stammt, aber ich fand's sehr schön, äh wie es dann,
überall, also wirklich alle haben geschrieben Netzpolitik, den Referentenentwurf gelegt, aber weil,
Andre wusste wo er herkommt, hat er auch nirgendwo geschrieben, dass es ein Leak wäre. Also wie dem auch sei, äh wir freuen uns natürlich, dass äh Netzkritik Org da mal wieder Kredit bekommen hat. Ähm.
Auch wenn's mal nicht ganz verdient war an dieser Stelle.
Du, ich würde vielleicht auch der jungen Dame, die mir den äh diesen Entwurf zugeschickt hat, dann auch irgendwann nochmal so eine Whistleblower Medaille verleihen, wenn wir es dann schaffen. Äh oder wenn wir es dann geschafft haben, auch dieses
diesen Gesetzesentwurf dann wegzuschmettern.
Aber es war jetzt keine eigenmächtige Entscheidung einer einzelnen Person, sondern es war schon das Ziel, äh diesen Entwurf jetzt auch mal unter die Leute zu bringen, um ihn diskutieren zu lassen. Ich glaube, das macht das auch so so ein bisschen aus. Man geht irgendwie schon automatisch davon aus
irgendwie so ein Gesetz, was jetzt auch wieder so aus dem Nichts heraus ähm vorbeschlossen wurde, sage ich mal, ja, also es ist ja noch nicht,
abgestimmt worden, sondern es ist ja nur ein Entwurf, dass ähm,
man tunlichst vermeidet, irgendetwas äh darüber bekannt werden zu lassen. Kurz, ganz kurz bis äh zu dem Zeitpunkt, bevor man eben tatsächlich,
Fassung macht. Das ist irgendwie schon so eine Erwartungshaltung und wenn's dann irgendwie ein paar Wochen schon mal vorher veröffentlicht wird, dann kommt einem das schon irgendwie merkwürdig voll. Wir sind ja auch schon konditioniert.
Ne, man man ist verwundert, dass äh dass ein Überwachungsgesetz, das uns äh gegen unseren gegen den breiteren Willen der Bevölkerung und gegen die Urteile der der höchstrichterlichen Institutionen in Deutschland und der EU,
Auge gedrückt werden soll,
dass wir so was überhaupt mal zu Gesicht bekommen, ja, das ist ja schon da, da freuen wir uns schon drüber und dass das irgendwie, dass das äh dann auch noch dass die Regierung eine derartige Transparenz
walten lassen würde, Gesetze, die sie uns aufs Auge drückt, vorher nochmal von uns äh einsehen und diskutieren zu lassen. Das ist inzwischen schon außerhalb der Vorstellungs,
Ja, nein, so ist es halt.
Ja, das ist wirklich absurd. Ja.
Ne? Vorratsdatenspeicherung heißt jetzt übrigens nicht mehr, Vorratsdatenspeicherung, weil das hatten wir schon. Ähm es es ist jetzt, also es gab ja viele Kandidaten, ne, Mindestspeicherfrist, digitale Sp
puren Sicherung. Was es nicht alles gab, der der Vortrag von Kai Biermann bei den Big Brother Awards, den ich empfohlen hatte, hat er ja die schönsten Begriffe schon gesammelt
and the winner is Einführung einer Speicherpflicht und einer höchst Speicherfrist für Verkehrsdaten
Eindeutig natürlich ausgewählt danach, dass es möglichst komplex und total unsinnig ist, auf das es keiner ausspreche, aber äh liebes äh,
Justizministerium, so etabliert man keinen neuen Begriffe, ja? Also gewonnen hätte man, wenn man einen Begriff gefunden hätte, der der kürzer und knackiger ist als vorher. Man versucht's ja jetzt eben über die,
Mindestspeicherfristen, aber steht da nicht äh steht da so jetzt nicht drin.
Ich hätte gerne noch, ich hätte ja noch einen Vorschlag. Wie wir den nennen können. Äh na, ich würd's die neue Maßlosigkeit nennen.
Ha, ha, auch nicht schlecht, auch nicht schlecht
gab's aber auch schon ein sehr schönes, sehr schönes Wortspiel zu
jetzt muss ich das gucken, wie war das denn? Ich habe dann auf Twitter irgendwie geschrieben, dass Sigmar Gabriel jetzt nicht so die die Idealbesetzung ist, um von jemand anderem Rückgrat zu fordern, weil er ja,
das von Angela Merkel habe ich nur mal angemerkt, ja. Habe ich nebenbei gemacht und was mache ich Vollpfosten, einen Rechtschreibfehler?
Und schreibe Rückgrat mit D. Da hatte der
Tweet aber dann schon zehnfachs und dann habe ich gedacht, naja, jetzt kannst du auch nicht mehr löschen. Außerdem kommen ja dann wieder irgendeiner kommt ja dann der Neumann hat einen Tweet gelöscht in bestimmten in bestimmten Regionen, ist ja Tweet löschen, ist ja so, das ist das Schlimmste, was man machen kann. Also habe ich dazu stehen lassen,
und dann hat.
Das Schlimmste, was man machen kann. Ich habe schon einige Tweets gelöscht. Aber nur, nur weil ich sie falsch geschrieben habe, dann habe ich sie nochmal neu gepostet.
Ja, lass dich nicht erwischen. Und wenn du Pech hast, wenn du falsch geschrieben, dann kommt ja der der dann kommt ja noch der, der ähm
Oberlehrer vorbei, ne. Aber Rückgrat hat er nicht. Der aber okay, Frank Rieger twitterte, dann twitterte dann Rückgrat mit dem. In Klammern Einheit, Winkel des Rückgrats zum Boden verwendet zur Messung politischer Unfall,
prozesse zuerst beschrieben von Ziffer. Da hat er mir dann so ein bisschen den Arsch gerette.
Sehr elegant.
Und dann twitterte, jetzt wollte ich extra mal hier den Namen nennen, aber das kann ich nicht aussprechen. Tut mir leid at FFC Unterstrich PUBL. Twitterte dann sozusagen eine Maßeinheit.
Okay. Ja, also da hätte ich jetzt auch niemals äh äh erwartet, dass ich der Erste äh bin, der ähm hier,
ähm mit dieser mit dem Gleichnis aufkommt, aber nichtsdestotrotz wäre es natürlich ein schöner Handelsname, der auf jeden Fall besser runtergeht, äh insbesondere für die Presse als Einführung einer Speicherpflicht und einer höchst Speicherfrist für Verkehrsdaten.
Er heißt Vorrat sein, ist eine Vorratsansprechung. Na ja, kommen wir mal kurz zum Inhalt, ne. Wir müssen ja auch, wir haben ja auch noch hier so eine.
Richtig Inhalte auch meinen. Stimmt. Ja, was ist denn da jetzt eigentlich drin? Äh ich habe gehört, das ist total verfassungskonform und äh die Bundesregierung hat totale Sorgfalt darauf gelegt, dass jetzt äh endlich, endlich alles äh supi ist,
und so verfass.
Ja, also genau, es geht ja darum, es gab ja Vorgaben von,
Es gab Begründungen des Bundesverfassungsgericht und des EuGHs warum die also das Gesetz Deutschlands und die EU-Richtlinie.
Mit den jeweiligen Verfassungen nicht vereinbar waren und genau ähm,
diese diese auf diese Begründungen einzugehen und diese Gründe für die Nicht-Verfassungsgemäßheit ähm zu entfernen, soll ja dann nach ähm Hoffnung.
Der unserer Herrenpolitiker dafür sorgen, dass man eben,
Eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung mit menschlichem Antlitz schafft, die man dann eben nicht mehr vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht äh weglagen kann. Ähm man will also den Rahmen
des gerade noch rechtlich möglichen irgendwie aufreizen. Und deshalb haben wir ja schon.
Auch als die Leitlinie veröffentlicht wurde, äh bekannt gegeben, dass es eben diese diese zehn Wochenfrist gibt, also eine kürzere Speicherfrist und einen Schutz von Berufsgeheimnisträgern, wo wir uns dann eben auch gefragt haben, wie soll das denn gehen,
Ähm und man kann auch davon ausgehen, dass es hoffentlich hoffentlich,
nicht reicht, denn die anlaslose Speicherung sämtlicher Telekommunikationsverbindungsdaten ohne jede Ausnahme,
Findet ja trotzdem statt, ja? Also die Berufsgeheimnisträger werden ja jetzt nicht von der Speicherung ausgenommen, sondern sie werden vom Abruf ausgenommen.
Und ähm es sind immer noch halt der Größere, der größere Teil, der zig Millionen davon erfassten Bürger stehen eben nicht,
in der Nähe irgendeiner äh Straftat und äh wir fallen dieser Opf dieser Speicherung eben äh völlig ungerechtfertigterweise zum Opfer und das hat sich da natürlich jetzt auch nicht geändert. Insofern,
mag man hoffen, dass es so bleibt. Also sie sagen, sie wollen Verbindungsdaten zehn und Standortdaten vier Wochen aufbewahren. Das wird auch nochmal sportlich, dass in den Datenbanken entsprechend sicherzustellen,
IP-Adressen rund um elektronische Post dürfen nicht gespeichert werden. Da wird's dann nochmal interessant ähm,
wie man den Begriff der elektronischen Post vielleicht nochmal in in weiteren Klagen äh definiert.
Da genau so drin.
Da erwischt du mich jetzt auf einem auf dem kalten Fuß, ähm da muss ich jetzt mal hier ähm Control F drücken.
Das scheint ja auch so eine besondere
wie soll ich sagen? Also ein besonderes Anliegen in der öffentlichen Kommunikation gewesen zu sein irgendwie zu behaupten zu können, dass ja, na ja, es würde ja jetzt wohl gespeichert werden, aber nicht eure E-Mail
Ja, also ich habe auch wieder so den Eindruck, das ist so als besonderes, äh besonders sensitives Ding. Also, ich meine, das ist ja schon ein Wunder, dass es überhaupt etwas Sensitives gibt, weil in gewisser Hinsicht empfinden wir ja die Bevölkerung der Bundesrepublik
äh Deutschland noch als verhältnismäßig ähm, wie soll ich sagen, nicht nur Beratungsresistent, sondern auch ähm na ja,
Im Großen und Ganzen ist ihnen ja diese ganze Überwachung bisher immer,
egal gewesen, ja, trotz alledem gibt's immer so Bereiche, da schlägt das dann wieder komplett ins Irrwitzige um und offensichtlich wurde von der Regierung das der Begriff,
E-Mail als ausreichend privat ähm lokalisiert, dass man da eine andere Formulierung wählen muss.
Paragraph einhundertdreizehn B ähm haste nicht gesehen. Ähm ja, dieses Entwurfs steht.
Der Inhalt der Kommunikation, Daten über aufgerufene Internetseiten und Daten von Diensten der elektronischen Post dürfen aufgrund dieser Vorschrift nicht gespeichert werden.
Hm. Da steht da so drin.
Und dann äh steht in der Begründung das ist mich sehr schön. Schon die Verpflichtung zur Speicherung wird,
Entsprechend den Anforderungen des Gerichtshofs der Europäischen Union auf das absolut Notwendigste beschränkt.
Daten von Diensten der elektronischen Post sind vollständig von der Speicherpflicht ausgenommen zum Schutz des besonderen Vertrauensverhältnisses,
Verkehrsdaten, die sich auf Personenbehörden und Organisationen in sozialen oder kirchlichen Bereichen beziehen, die grundsätzlich anonym bleibenden Anrufern ganz lalala. Ähm.
Grundsätzlich von der Speicherpflicht ausgenommen, interessant. Da bin ich mal sehr gespannt, wie sie das umsetzen werden.
Vor allem äh sehr gespannt, wie sie das definieren wollen, weil ich äh würde ja jetzt noch einhundertseitiges Dokument in der Anlage ähm vermuten, indem mal definiert ist, was elektronische Post denn ist.
Genau, das haben sie hier nicht getan. Das wird das wird dann noch mal ein Einfalltor. Aber wie gesagt, das Ziel darf gar nicht erst sein, sich hier irgendwie auf äh auf ähm die
unscharfen Definitionen zu stürzen, denn davon gibt es massige in diesem Gesetzesentwurf
äh äh in diesem Gesetzesentwurf. Das Ziel muss einfach sein, den vollständig direkt wieder äh einsacken zu lassen, ja. Ähm die,
Von Anrufenden und angerufenen Anschlüssen,
International Mobile zum Scriper Identify ist die INCE, also das was den den Anschluss definiert im Mobilfunk sowie die IMEI International Mobile Equipment Identify, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Also um es mal einfacher auszudrücken, die Sim und das Telefon.
Ja, ja, ja. Ich wollte jetzt einmal hier mit Fachwissen.
Und ich wollte so tun als würden würde es uns als hätten wir ein Interesse daran, verständlich rüberzukommen.
Standortdaten,
ähm nur künftig und in Echtzeit, wenn es für die Erforschung des Sachverhalts oder die Ermittlungen des Aufenthaltsortes, des Beschuldigten erforderlich ist,
Was auch wieder so geil. Also ich mein, was ist das für eine geile Einschränkung?
Das darfst du aber nur, wenn es für die Erforschung des Sachverhalts oder die Ermittlung des Aufenthaltes des Beschuldigten erforderlich ist. Ja.
Sonst mit den Daten machen als einen Sachverhalt erforschen oder die Ermittlung des Aufenthaltsortes äh machen, wenn du wenn du Standortdaten abgreifst, ja also das ist wieder so eine Einschränkung, die keine ist. Ähm,
Und dann interessanterweise Gefahrenabwehrbehörden dürfen ohne Richter Vorbehalt auf Nutzerinformationen äh zugreifen und auch dynamischer IPs auflösen. Nicht aber bei Ordnungswidrigkeiten
ja? Ähm das ist dieser klassische Fall.
Ähm sagen wir mal jemand, beleidigt einen anderen in einem Online-Forum. Das ist dann eben nicht, ist glaube ich keine Ordnungswidrigkeit mehr, eine Beleidigung. Ähm,
und dann dürfen die also ohne Richtervorbehalt die die Halterfeststellung ähm.
Machen, ja? Äh genau, äh Beleidigung ist STGB. Es ist keine Ordnungswidrigkeit.
Kannst du das nochmal mit der Gefahrenabwehrbehörde äh.
Ja, Polizei, ne, oder? Also, ich.
Kannst du nochmal diese Formulierung nochmal ganz kurz äh mit der Gefahrenabwehrbehörde, also den Gefahrenabwehr, Behörden wird sozusagen Zugriffsrecht.
Dieses Recht gegeben, ja. Also das Entscheidende ist nicht, dass es Gefahrenabwehrbehörden sind, sondern der der der interessante Begriff ist hier der des Richter Vorbehaltes, ja? Also jemand möchte.
Herausfinden, wem eine IP-Adresse gehört, ja? Geht ohne Richterbeschluss. Kannste einfach.
Finde diese, finde diese Definition Gefahrenabwehrbehörde ganz gut. Also so äh mit schnell mal nachschlagen, äh habe ich hier zum Beispiel auch eine Bauordnungsbehörde äh in der Klassifikation Gefahrenabwehrbehörde äh gefunden.
Ist ein interessanter Sammelbegriff.
Die allgemeinen Ordnungsbehörden sind damit benannt. Und dann das Mais heißt natürlich in der Regel äh äh Polizei, ne.
Alle.
Ordnungsamt wäre eben hier jetzt nicht mit dazu, weil Ordnungsamt kümmert sich um Ordnungswidrigkeiten, ja? Also, das ist glaube der Begriff hat da jetzt, glaube ich, keine, keine besondere Bedeutung an an der Stelle,
ich muss auch mal ganz kurz gucken, ob der.
Gefahrenabwehrbehörde der Länder steht hier öfter drin, aber der kommt auch nur einmal vor ja so.
Entscheidend ist der Richtervorbehalt fällt beim Zugriff auf IP-Adressen. Ähm,
Der Richtervorbehalt, den gibt's nur noch bei Vollabgriff der Vorratsdaten. Das heißt, wenn du wirklich sagst, Person X.
Ähm einmal alles bitte. Ja? Das ist dann der da musst du dann einen Richter haben, der da kurz sein sein Larry drunter malt. Ähm aber es gibt ja noch so einen,
kleinen Abgriff, nämlich also wenn die Polizei einfach wissen möchte, wer hat denn zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt eine IP-Adresse gehabt,
und dann muss der Provider unter Rückgriff auf die Vorratsdaten dieser Auskunft geben.
Und jetzt wird der wird die Kundige Hörerin feststellen.
IP-Adressenauflösung machen die doch heute auch schon die ganze Zeit. Wie machen sie es denn?
Bisher machen sie es so, dass es über äh Telekommunikationsgesetz Telemediengesetz geregelt ist, dass ähm Verkehrsdaten zur Störungsdirektion.
Äh gesammelt werden dürfen. Und,
diese genau auf diese Daten wird dann zugegriffen. Deswegen ist das ja auch so kritisch, dass im IT-Sicherheitsgesetz, dass äh wieder quasi ausgeweitet werden soll, dass man sagt, ihr dürft mehr speichern. Ähm,
Aber da gibt's eben keine Pflicht wie lange
ja? Und da da gibt's da auch eine sehr große Varianz. Und in den Vorratsdatengesetzenspeicherungsgesetz soll jetzt gesagt werden, so zehn Wochen, zack. Und da du diesen Datenpool hast, dürfen auch unsere Polizeibehörden
dir einfach mal so eine IP-Adressenauflösung ohne Richtervorbehalt aus diesem Datenpool sofort von dir bekommen.
Gleichzeitig haben sie, haben sie aber immer noch äh diese Hintertür nach Paragraf einhundert TKG, ähm sodass du quasi
da kann die Polizei ja auch nochmal äh drauf zugreifen. Und da gibt's Speicherfristen zwischen einigen Tagen und sechs Monaten.
Ja? Ähm in in der in der ähm bei den Providern,
Ja? Und diese werden dafür haben sie keine äh Speicherfrist ähm äh Vorgaben. Das heißt, man könnte jetzt sogar sagen, dass diese,
Dieser Zugriff auf die Daten von Paragraph einhundert PKG eben jetzt auch problemlos ohne Richtervorbehalt äh möglich sein wird.
Dann haben sie noch ein ein neuen Paragrafen da mit drin, ähm uns da wird also ein neuer Straftatbestand ähm,
eingeführt und zwar der, der Datenhellerei. Und das ist der Paragraph zweihunderteins D. Wer Daten.
Nicht allgemein zugänglich sind und die ein anderer durch eine rechtswidrige Tat erlangt hat,
sich oder einem anderen verschafft, einem anderen überlässt,
verbreitet oder sonst zugänglich macht, um sich oder einen Dritten zu bereichern oder einen anderen zu schädigen,
wird mit Freiheitsstrafe bis zu drei Jahren oder mit Geldstrafe bestraft. So.
Jetzt stellen wir uns mal vor.
Ähm dahin, die nicht allgemein zugänglich sind. Also ein ähm.
Ein, ein äh Gesetzesentwurf, ja? Ähm die ein anderer durch eine rechtswidrige Tat erlangt hat, in dem Fall ich, weil das BMJ hat mir rechtswidrig, behaupten wir jetzt mal, war ja nicht so, ne. Aber war nicht allgemein zugänglich,
Die rechtswidrige Tat wurde von dem BM äh J begangen, indem ich sie bekommen habe. Dadurch habe ich bin ich, ich bin gerade der andere, habe sie durch eine rechtswidrige Tat erlangt,
Und jetzt beschafft der andere sich die oder und macht sie,
zugänglich, um sich oder einen Dritten zu bereichern oder an die anderen zu schädigen. Netzpolitik Org muss ähm
bezahlt Gehälter, also bereichert der André sich ähm finanziell und schädigt einen anderen, nämlich äh die Bundesregierung, indem er das veröffentlicht.
Wird mit Freiheitsstrafe bis zu drei Jahren oder mit Geldstrafe bestraft. Also Andre ab in Bau.
Ja, Schwein.
Ulf Burmeier hat in einem Artikel das mal sehr interessant dargestellt, weil es erst, wenn da die, wenn da wirklich drei Personen drin sind, äh
greift diese Definition, ne, also der
Ulf als Verfassungsrichter schaut da natürlich sehr genau drauf, was dieser, was dieser Satz wirklich aussagt. Aber okay, es geht denen offensichtlich darum, ich denke mal, in der finalen Version wird dieser Satz nochmal bereinigt werden. Allein, weil er
weiß ich nicht, eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs Komma da hat und über drei Zeilen geht, werden sie da eventuell noch mal äh den den einfacher formulieren.
Also äh Ulf ist kein Verfassungsrichter, um das nochmal kurz.
Verfasst verfassungsrechtler habe ich aber auch.
Rechtler. Und ich habe Richter verstanden. Ich weiß.
Strafrichter, oder?
Ja, ja, er ist äh Richter am Landgericht Berlin, aber ich dachte, der ist jetzt verfassungsrichter gesagt, vielleicht hast du nur Richter gesagt, dann nehme ich das zurück. Ich wollte nur.
Aber es ist gut, besser.
Genau.
So, äh die die Strafe darf nicht schwerer sein als die für die Vortat angedrohte Strafe. Absatz eins,
gilt nicht Verhandlungen, die ausschließlich der Erfüllung rechtmäßiger dienstlicher oder beruflicher Pflichten dienen.
Dazu gehören insbesondere solche Handlungen von Amtsträgern oder deren Beauftragten,
mit den Daten ausschließlich der Verwertung in einem Besteuerungsverfahren, einem Strafverfahren oder einem Ordnungswidrigkeitsverfahren zugeführt werden sollen.
Also mit anderen Worten, die Regierung darf nach wie vor Steuer-CDs kaufen.
Mhm. Und alle anderen.
Aber die Presse darf aber nicht äh die Presse darf aber nicht mehr frei berichten, weil wo kommen wir denn da hin?
So
meine naive Lesart. Es gibt da jetzt Streitereien drüber, das überlasse ich lieber den Juristen und warte auf die ähm finale.
Auf die finale Formulierung, bevor ich da irgendwie meinen meine nicht vorhandene Expertise drüber gieße aber man sieht auf jeden Fall, was was dieser Paragraph soll, ja? Sie wollen halt äh,
irgendwie äh da das Liegen und Whistleblown äh durchaus irgendwie mal äh in seine Schranken weisen.
Ist schon nicht ganz uninteressant, dass das äh vor allem im Zuge dieser Gesetzgebung kommt, ne, zumal es ja jetzt erstmal gar nichts damit zu tun hat.
Das ist genau meine, das ist genau meine meine Frage hier. Was hat das denn damit zu tun? Wollen sie damit irgendwie äh denen beikommen, bei denen nachher die ganzen ähm
bei denen nachher die ganzen Daten liegen,
Ja, das das Risiko gibt's ja auch noch. Es ist relativ unklar. Ich würde da nochmal, wie gesagt, ich würde gerne auf die finale Formulierung abwarten
aber man kann glaube ich jetzt schon festhalten, für die Pressefreiheit wird das jetzt nicht unbedingt ein besonders toller Paragraph sein.
Nee, das ist auf jeden Fall auch genug Anlass, da mal ordentlich äh drauf rumzuhauen, weil ich finde, alles, was auch nur den Hauch
den Hauch eines Anfluges, eines äh eines Verdachts hat äh in diese Richtung genutzt werden zu können, sollte mit der größtmöglichen Keule ordentlich
platt gemacht werden, zumal ja auch noch die ganze Zeit darüber hatten wir auch schon in der letzten oder vorletzten Sendung äh drüber gesprochen jedoch diese generelle Einschränkungen, in der Zielsetzung dieses gesamten Gesetzes ja drin ist, ja
wir schützen ja Berufsgeheimnisträger, ja? Und und da ist halt
Kommt ihr zwei Sachen mit rein. Erstens, was du schon angesprochen hast, so äh wo ist jetzt hier bitte der Schutz, ja? Und B also wie wird der sozusagen auch technisch äh realisiert, wenn zunächst einmal alles gespeichert wird? Und ähm vor allem,
was bedeutet Beruf im Hinblick auf Journalismus, weil Beruf ist, wofür ich Geld kriege, ja,
eingeschränkten Maße auch noch, wofür ich ausgebildet oder zugelassen bin.
Das mag bei manchen Berufsbildern recht klar zu fassen zu sein wie Medizinern.
Mit Einschränkungen auch noch bei äh Juristen, die ja auch eine Zulassung haben oder nicht et cetera. Aber im Bereich Presse, ne? Ich meine, wir sind Presse,
Nicht, dass wir jetzt groß damit hausieren gehen würden, äh Journalisten zu sein. Aber wir sind es in dem Moment, wo wir sagen, dass wir es sind.
Dazu muss ich jetzt keinen, keine Ausbildung äh gemacht haben und gelernt haben, wie ich mit Quark-Express-Dokumentlay oute. Kann ich aber auch.
Langes her. Ähm und ja, das muss an der Stelle einfach mal klar sein. Das das ist auch vor allem ist keine Nachlässigkeit ist, sondern es ist ein,
Designziel gewesen,
bei der Gründung der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, dass eben nicht explizit an so eine Berufsausbildung zu kippen, damit eben die Presse frei ist
und man eben nicht über solche Berufsausschuss äh Verfahren et cetera eine Berichterstattung verhindern kann.
Ich habe jetzt gerade mal noch einen Blick darauf geworfen,
auf die auf die Begründung, also Gesetzen es liegt immer auch nochmal eine Begründung an, äh die das versucht zu erläutern oder schmackhaft zu machen, aber das ist auch wirklich das stehen nur Sätze, denen du nicht lesen kannst,
ähm also es ist wirklich großartig. Hier also Absatz eins der also
Absatz eins lautet,
wer Daten, die nicht allgemein zugänglich sind und die ein anderer durch eine rechtswidrige Tat erlangt hat, sich oder einem anderen verschafft, einem anderen überlässt, verbreitet oder sonst zugänglich macht, um sich oder einen Dritten zu bereichern oder einen anderen zu schädigen, wird mit Freiheitsstrafe bis zu drei Jahren oder mit Geldstrafe
bestraft. In der Begründung findet sich dann der Satz,
Nach der Vorschrift nach der Vorschrift macht sie strafbar. Wer Daten, die ein anderer durch eine rechtswidrige Tat erlangt hat, sich oder einem anderen verschafft, einem anderen überlässt, verbreitet oder sonst zugänglich macht, um sich oder einen Dritten zu bereichern oder einen anderen zu stetigen.
Also einfach der gleiche Satz nochmal. Ähm und es ist einfach also ein bisschen umgeschoben, paar weniger Komma drin.
Ist verboten, weil es verboten.
Naja und dann haben sie halt, dann haben sie's halt zugemüllt mit irgendwelchen Urteilen und und Paragrafen, damit's bloß niemand verstehen kann, ja, also das ist äh üblicherweise kenne ich eher,
tatsächlich drin steht ähm was wollen wir damit bezwecken? Ja und das sehe ich hier ähm.
Mich. Also hier wird die ganze Zeit nur irgendwie so referenziert aufgrund der bestehenden Strafbarkeitslücken hat sich der deutsche Juristentag für die Einführung entschieden. Also da haben sie wirklich.
Das ist ein einziges Cover myS Dokument, wo sie ohne Ende irgendwo sich drauf beziehen wollen, um zu sagen, ja, ja, wir sind hier ähm,
Wir machen das alles ordentlich und mit mit Einklang in Einklang mit mit äh der Prophezeiung so ungefähr.
Was muss man jetzt tun? So, die Opposition ist sowieso dagegen, die CDU ist sowieso dafür.
Verbrochen hat's die SPD. Sigmar Gabriel äh seine Position dazu kennen wir.
Will einerseits der Merkel an ans Bein pinkeln, weil sie weil sie diesen äh NSA BND-Skandal an der Backe hat und uns gleichzeitig eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung äh in die Rippen wirken
also der Typ ist halt offensichtlich auch nicht mehr zurechnungsfähig.
Ist echt schizophren, ey.
Fordert dann noch Rückgrat, aber das hatten wir ja schon.
Heiko Maas, ja, lange gekämpft, aber am Ende eben doch, ja, bewiesen, dass er Sozialdemokrat ist. Und ähm,
das ist die Partei, an der es, äh an der es jetzt hängt, an niemand anderem. In der CDU wirst du niemanden umstimmen, die Opposition ähm war immer dagegen, ist ja auch Opposition.
Mhm. Die SPD war halt nicht immer Opposition, deswegen ist sie halt mal dafür ein Mal dagegen.
Und deswegen hat sie uns,
den ersten Vorratsdatenspeicherungs, das erste Vorratsdatenspeicherungsgesetz gebracht und will uns jetzt auch das zweite geben. Also, auf die SPD drauf kloppen,
ähm E-Mail schreiben,
erklären, warum das alles Unsinn ist. Ähm wir müssen die Messer wetzen, wir müssen unsere Juristen mal wieder bemühen.
Und ähm ja, was willst du da jetzt noch machen? Es gab irgendwie eine sehr schöne, also diese, dieser, dieser Streit zwischen.
Zwischen Gabriel und Merkel ähm wollte ich eigentlich später drauf eingehen, aber äh,
Wie gesagt, der Gabe nimmt ja jetzt die ähm die Merkel wegen der dieser Selektorenliste, die wir der wir die letzte Sendung aus ausführlich gewidmet haben,
in die Zange und sagt sie, sie müssen jetzt äh Rückgrat gegenüber den USA zeigen und da gab's eine sehr schöne Antwort von Unionsfraktionsvize Michael Fuchs.
Der sagte dann, was wäre denn, wenn Angela Merkel jetzt über die Vertrauensfrage im Bundestag den Weg zuvor gezogenen Neuwahlen sucht.
Ja, was wäre denn dann? Die SPD ist absolut im Keller. Die hat ja, die hat ja äh Gabriel bald äh runtergewirtschaftet, wie wie nach nach einer nach irgendwie zehn Jahren Agenda zwanzig zehn.
Die haben doch also die haben ja gar nichts mehr. Es ist eigentlich ein Witz, dass der sich überhaupt noch äh noch freut äh noch noch traut öffentlich aufzutreten. Aber okay, der den den bevor ich mich jetzt in Rage rede, möchte ich nur noch kurz anmerken
dass die SPD ja auch den, der den ähm den kleinen,
Gewerkschaften jetzt auch gerade wieder das Messer in den Rücken gerahmt hat, ne. Wir sehen uns irgendwie äh die SPD distanziert sich ja nicht distanziert sich nicht nur von den Lokführern, die jetzt grade mal wieder streiken.
Sondern hat ja ein äh Gesetz auf den Weg gebracht und trägt es mit, was die äh die Einflussmöglichkeit von kleineren Gewerkschaften schwächt, ne.
Also okay, das nur am Rande. SPD ist ähm.
Ja aber damit ist genau, also äh finde den Aspekt gut, ähm was kann man, was kann man tun, ja? Und an der Stelle ist es äh ziemlich klar, hier müssen,
muss den SPD Bundestagsabgeordneten ein ähm wackeliges Gefühl gegeben werden,
Dabei hilft, ein Anruf eures SPD-Bundestagsabgeordneten, der also zuständig ist für eure Gemeinde und dann könnt ihr mal in erschütterten Worten schildern, wie ähm,
ja, wie dramatisch ihr das doch äh seht, jetzt wo die Pressefreiheit komplett eingestampft werden soll von der SPD.
Und was ihr sonst noch so an Argumenten äh aus dieser Sendung vielleicht noch zusammengekratzt bekommt. Aber ich denke mal, gerade das mit der Pressefreiheit,
Das ist ein schönes Ding.
Verstehst du? Das ist so wie klar, das ist irgendwie das ist das versteht jeder. Also diese die.
Also da gibt's, da gibt's ja auch schon wieder Debatten, ne, wo dann irgendwelche ähm hm also da gibt es auch Leute, die dann sagen, das hat Pressefreiheit, so ist das ja nicht gemeint, so wie du.
Nee, klar, ich meine, du kannst kannst da du kannst natürlich alles äh komplett wegdiskutieren. Aber wenn deine Bürger, die dich gewählt haben, die du repräsentierst,
sagen, ist mir scheißegal, wie du das jetzt schön redest. Ich bin hier besorgt. Und ich bin dagegen. Das ist irgendwie das, was als relevant,
angesehen wird, weil am Ende ist denen ihr eigener Bundestags äh noch tausendmal lieber als äh das gesamt der Gesamtzustand äh,
der Koalition, weißt du? Und und grade wenn jetzt hier so ein so ein äh
CDU-Vize äh daherkommen mit hier schöne Koalition haben sie da, ja? Doch, wär doch schade, wenn der was äh passieren würde, dann ja, dann ist das einfach das Einfallstor, was ich für am
halte, denn das ist mitnichten so, dass es jetzt in der SPD eine Einheitsfront für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gäbe.
Nein, das stimmt. Und da müssen wir halt hoffen, dass dass die ähm,
die Ketzer in der SPD äh sich durchsetzen und äh dafür sorgen, dass es da einfach, dass die, dass die ähm,
Gewissen verpflichteten Bundestagsabgeordneten von diesem Gewissen einfach mal Gebrauch machen.
Genau, einmal zumindest mal.
Einmal im.
Einmal los. Einmal.
Beziehungsweise, ganz ehrlich, das werden die noch öfter machen. Nee, vielleicht auch nicht SPD. Da die müssten ja nur von ihrem Gewissen Gebrauch machen, wenn sie in der Regierung sind und das ist bei der SPD jetzt erstmal nicht,
Stall gemeißelt, aber.
Steht nicht an.
Ja okay, kommen wir mal zum nächsten Thema. Es gibt hier es gibt ja noch viel, viel mehr Schönes. Es gibt ja noch viel mehr schöne Neuigkeit.
Noch schöner? Was denn?
Ja und zwar meldete sich letzte Woche schon der.
Österreichische Nationalratsabgeordnete Peter Pilz,
seines Zeichens Sicherheitssprecher der Grünen in Österreich zu Wort und erstattete Strafanzeige bei der Staatsanwaltschaft Wien,
denn.
Die Deutsche Telekom und der BND haben gemeinsam im Rahmen der Operation Eyconal bis zu einunddreißig Staaten in Europa ausgespäht, sechsundzwanzig davon,
EU-Staaten. Ähm Österreich und Luxemburg haben dann entsprechend heute äh die Strafanzeigen ähm
eingereicht. Ähm letzte Woche wurde das Beweismaterial dafür gelegt, davon eben Peter Pilz. Da ging's also um einerseits eine E-Mail, in der ein Telekom,
ähm Techniker bestätigt, dass die gewünschten ähm Abhörschleifen jetzt gelegt wurden.
Da ist die Rede von einem äh STM eins. Das ist also eine äh Glasfaser ähm,
nach einem ITU-Standard ähm,
die hat eine Übertragungskapazität von einhundertfünfundfünfzig Komma fünf zwei Mbit. Da denkt man sich erstmal, oh, das ist aber relativ wenig nach heutigem Stand,
denn diese E-Mail stammt auch von zweitausendfünf. Ja
Operation Alconal. Wir reden also äh von einer lange, lange Zeit geplanten oder lange Zeit zurückliegenden äh Besprechungen, die da stattfindet und die Hauptbetroffenen Fasern, die dort eben auf diesem STM eins gespiegelt wurden,
Ähm sind ähm haben Endpunkte in Österreich und in Luxemburg. Ähm.
Also so ein so ein so antik ist das nicht, ne, sondern das ist halt ganz normale Telekom-Technik, mit der die Telefonnetze äh aufgebaut sind weltweit.
Genau. Ähm nur für für Internet äh Datenkapazitäten äh klingt das jetzt natürlich ein bisschen äh mager. Äh in unserer, in unserer.
Aber davon haben sie da auch ganz viele von.
Genau, deswegen haben sie mehrere und äh da ist dann auch in der E-Mail von die Rede. Nächste Woche schalten wir die nächste. Ähm jetzt.
Kurz aus dem Takt gebracht. Genau, Österreich und Luxemburg sind da in der in der Regel betroffen.
Die Vermutung liegt nahe, dass das alles in Frankfurt äh da einander geklatscht wurde, kommt ja auch ähm bei den,
Wie gesagt, insgesamt äh sind das viele, viele Leitungen ähm
kommt auch geographisch immer hin, dass Frankfurter mehr oder weniger wahrscheinlich der der Punkt ist. Gleichzeitig hat er aber noch geliebt, einen Vertrag, in dem die damalige T-Com,
äh mit dem BND verspricht allen elektronischen Verkehr zuzuleiten, der in Deutschland weder Ursprung noch Ziel hat, den sogenannten Transitverkehr.
Ähm,
Betroffen sind von diesem Vertrag sowohl leitungs als auch Paket vermittelter Verkehr, Leitungs vermittelt ist, also ist also die klassische Telekommunikation, Paket vermittelt, also äh,
IP äh ist dann der eher der der Internetverkehr, also Faxe, Telefonate, Internet. Ähm,
und die in diesem Vertrag verpflichtet sich die Telekom Informationen aus allgemein zugänglichen und internen Quellen zu beschaffen,
Damit also dem BND zu melden, was abgreifbar ist und wie es abgreifbar ist, also technisch. Und dann,
Planungsmäßige Umsetzung von Auftragsrelevanten Intentionen in technisch realisierbare Anwendungen zu überführen. Das heißt auch die die das Abhören dann,
durchzuführen, das heißt mehr oder weniger die Telekom verpflichtet, die verpflichtet sich, den BND zu sagen, hier, das gibt's, da könnte man was dran halten, äh dann sagt der BND, wie denn? Und dann sagt die, die kommen ja auch so und so, können wir machen.
Außerdem sollen sie die entsprechenden Spione beim BND aus und weiterbilden und,
Jetzt denkt man sich natürlich so, oh krass, dicker Vertrag, ordentliches Volumen, langjährige Zusammenarbeit, viel Technik mit im Spiel. Was kriegt denn die T-Com dafür?
Sechseinhalbtausend Euro plus Spesen. Spesen in dem Fall halt die ganze Technik, ne? Die sind da nicht mit drin, die muss der Tiko auch nicht bezahlen. Das heißt, da die die Rechnung haben sie dann durchgereicht an dem BND. Sechseinhalbtausend Euro im Monat.
An einen Millionenkonzern. Das war das ist nichts. Das ist äh,
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich dann eine oder zwei Stellen, die damit nochmal ist eine Stelle, eine Stelle, wahrscheinlich am Ende, die damit nochmal beschafft wurde, äh die dann irgendwie äh den ganzen Kram umsetzt, ne.
Deutsche Telekom hat dazu Stellung bezogen und verweist darauf, ähm wie alle anderen Telekommunikationsnetzanbieter in Deutschland sind sie zu der Zusammenarbeit mit dem BND verpflichtet.
Insofern ist der veröffentlichte Vertrag nur die Umsetzung dieser rechtlichen Verpflichtung, für die es eine Aufwandsentschädigung gegeben hat.
Anderen Worten, die bestätigen, dass der Vertrag echt ist.
Man halte sich aber streng an die rechtlichen Grundlagen. Äh der Vorwurf nicht gesetzeskonform verhalten äh gehandelt zu haben, den weisen sie natürlich von sich äh und mit ausländischen Operdienst äh ausländischen Diensten kooperieren man nicht,
und über die BND Kooperation mit der NSA war uns nichts bekannt.
Peter Pilz hat das natürlich dann seine Strafanzeige äh übrigens auch gegen die Personen gerichtet, ne? Also gegen die Institution und die Person. Ähm,
und das dann flankiert mit einer Reihe an Fragen an die Bundesregierung,
welche Daten von von Personen aus seinem Heimatland ausgeleitet wurden, welche Selektoren der NSA zum Einsatz gekommen sind, welche Überwachungsziele äh und welche Überwachungsziele es ging
von Angela Merkel erwartet er eine umfassende Aufklärung.
Und so weiter, denn jetzt ist sie, wir erinnern uns alle an das Merkel-Handy und jetzt ist sie nicht mehr Opfer, sondern.
Chefin der Tatverdächtigen.
Das ist jetzt natürlich eine andere Rolle. Und ich würde an der Stelle noch ganz gerne darauf hinweisen, erinnert sich noch jemand an ähm Schlandnett.
Kennst du noch Schlandnett?
Alles nach Deutschland.
Alles durch Deutschland ruhen. Kennst du noch Schengen-Rout.
Schland ist richtig geil. Ja, muss ja.
Schengenrouting. Das ist anderthalb, zwei, ah, das ist wahrscheinlich ja doch, muss jetzt bald zwei Jahre her sein. Als die große Forderung war, ähm ja, wenn die USA das alles abgreifen, ne.
Da müssen wir Schengen-Routing machen. Am besten im Netz der Deutschen Telekom, die hat ja schon so ein schönes Netz.
Total sicher.
Also,
das hier ist, das hier ist richtig, das ist richtig dicker Shit. Das wird einem das, das überrascht einen jetzt irgendwie vielleicht gar nicht mehr so und man liest man liest sich das so durch und denkt, aha, mhm aber das heißt nichts anderes, als dass der BND,
schon seit ja mindestens zehn Jahren die EU ähm äh ausspioniert und zwar für die NSA.
Unter Zuhilfenahme der Deutschen Telekom.
Unter Zuhilfenahme der deutschen Telekom.
Geile Nummer. Ich meine, wir wir sind nicht wirklich überrascht, aber es ist mal schön zu sehen, wenn sowas auch mal ähm belegt wird. Versteht aber wahrscheinlich auch schon kein Mensch mehr.
Das ist das ist das ist halt mein das ist halt mal ein richtiges, dickes Ei.
Ja und ich bin mal sehr, sehr äh gespannt, wie die aus der Nummer wieder rauskommen, denn bis jetzt sind sie aus jeder Nummer rausgekommen. Ich habe keinen Zweifel daran, dass sie auch aus der Nummer wieder rauskommen.
Ja, ich meine, glaubst doch nicht ernsthaft, dass Österreich überrascht ist.
Österreich nun überrascht wird da nirgendwo ihr noch irgendwo jemand sein auf dieser Ebene aber vielleicht haben ja vielleicht gibt's ja in diesen Ländern.
Auch noch mal so Bürger, die vielleicht einfach sagen so, ey, et reicht langsam mit den scheiß Deutschen. So und das fände ich auch, also müsste man echt mal langsam, also.
Da gibt's bestimmt einige, die so denke.
Da gibt's einige.
Da muss man nicht weit fahren.
Mhm.
So und das äh ja, ich bin also ich bin.
Ja, ich bin ich bin eigentlich nur entsetzt mit was für einer, mit was für einer scheiß Ruhe die Angela Merkel wie immer, ne,
grandios, grandios, wie sie das hinkriegt, ja, die hat einfach verstanden. Krise ist dann, wenn du nervös bist, solange du einfach nur rumsitzt und den Leuten Ruhe und Gelassenheit und Sicherheit vermittelt, vermittelst, äh fliegt hier nix um die Ohren.
Land vollkommen gegen die Wand steuern, kannst den größten Scheiß bauen, so lange bleibst du am Ende auch nicht in der Regierung, dass irgendjemand noch merkt, dass du das alles zu verantworten hast,
Und wenn, hast du ja eh am Ende nichts zu verantworten. War ja nun mal leider so.
Ja.
Letzte Woche haben wir uns lange darüber unterhalten, äh wie der jetzt schon langsam die die Bauernopfer strategisch positioniert werden.
Da sind bestimmt noch ein paar Reihen abzuräumen, bevor es wirklich äh an die Kanzlerin geht. Ich meine, zumindest so äh an der Leitartikelfront scheint es ein wenig zu äh bröseln, aber äh ich glaube auch, wenn so die Intelligenz ja
jetzt mal ein wenig die Nase rümpft, dann ist das irgendwie alles noch nicht ausreichend.
Ja, ich bin mal gespannt. Ich meine, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht ähm ich meine,
Am Ende wird man sich fragen so, na ja, welche diplomatischen Konsequenzen kann Österreich ziehen, ähm die Deutschland in irgendwie die Deutschland irgendwie traurig machen im Vergleich zu den diplomatischen Konsequenzen, die die USA ziehen können?
Aber was man hier, was hier, glaube ich, wieder einmal sehr eindrucksvoll gezeigt wird, ist, es ist halt diese Geheimdienste,
Unternehmen, die mit ihnen kooperieren, diese Regierungen sind vollständig außerrannt und Band,
die entziehen sich jeglicher Kontrolle und die durchsetzen unser Zusammenleben. Und wir müssen.
Wir können da jetzt nicht irgendwie mit einem kleinen Reformchen drangehen. Ja.
Aber es war wahrscheinlich noch noch nie anders, ja? Also einfach gar nicht vorstellen, dass das jetzt ein Trend der letzten Jahre ist.
Nein, überhaupt nicht, sieht man ja jetzt auch, ne. Ich meine, diese gerade in letzter Zeit geht's ja Jahre und Jahrzehnte zurück. Wo womit wir uns befassen.
Ja, ich meine, du kannst natürlich genauso davon ausgehen, dass auch in Österreich äh mit denselben Mitteln gearbeitet wird,
und eine Empörung auf irgendeinem Regierungslevel, ja, könnte maximal so.
Also es ist eigentlich gar keine Empörung, sondern die reimen sich sozusagen so ein bisschen die Hände, weil ja, jetzt sind die mal wieder aufgeflogen. Aber wir ja noch nicht.
Na, also der Peter Pilz hat's sich dann nicht nehmen lassen, zu sagen, ausspähen unter Freunden. Da geht ja gar nicht.
Geht gar nicht.
Super. Ja, geht nicht.
Ja, also das köchelt jetzt so langsam hoch. Ähm da gibt's auch noch mehr Material.
Das ist aber noch nicht öffentlich. Insofern bin ich mal gespannt, was da noch. Also da kommen noch da kommt noch wat. Das Thema wird uns hoffentlich noch einige Zeit ähm beschäftigen.
Ja, ein weiteres Thema äh sind wir soweit?
Ja, ich will irgendwie nur nochmal so sagen, so, ich meine, so dieses diese Opferrolle oder so, ne, die die Deutschland sich da jetzt die.
In denen sich die Deutsch-deutsche Bevölkerung, die deutschen Artikelschreiber ähm,
gegenüber den USA da so lange Zeit gewählt haben, die ist natürlich jetzt wirklich mal endgültig vom Tisch, ne?
Also es gibt ja immer noch so dieses, ja, unsere Souveränität wird bedroht und so, ne? Ich meine, wir haben das, glaube ich, in in unseren Sendungen schon
häufig genug auch zum Ausdruck gebracht, dass ähm dass es hier eben um eine Kooperation geht und dass dass da alle die Schnauze halten, weil sie da Knie tief mit im Sumpf stecken, ne,
Aber es sollte jetzt auch jetzt, ich hoffe, dass das jetzt der Auslöser vielleicht ist, dass es auch wirklich nochmal alle verstehen.
Also ich meine, was kann man denn daraus letzten Endes festhalten? Meine das, dass jetzt sozusagen der BND, wie der GC GCAQ, ein führender äh Vasall, der des amerikanischen Geheimdienstes ist.
Und da bin ich mir noch nicht mal da bin ich vielleicht also eine ich weiß nicht, ob das überhaupt so eine Vasallenrolle ist, ne? Also es kann sein, dass das so ist. Ähm.
Aber wahrscheinlich machen's alle, also ne, die der BND hatten wir doch, was war diese Zahl? Vierhundertfünfunddreißig oder vierhunderteinunddreißig Geheimdienste der Welt, mit denen der BND kooperiert? Klar, da gibt's große, da gibt's große.
Da gibt's große und da gibt's kleine und die haben entsprechende ähm Kräfte ähm.
Und Einflussmöglichkeiten in den Verhandlungen und Erpressungen untereinander, aber.
Sollten wir äh das äh überübernächste Thema einfach mal vorziehen, weil ich glaube, das passt äh in dem Zusammenhang eigentlich ganz gut.
Ja wir äh du meinst äh ja das das kann man echt an der Stelle mal. Das kann man an der Stelle echt mal schön vorziehen. Ähm.
Für diejenigen du meinst Bin Laden, ne?
Ich meine, Bin Laden.
Wunderbar. Nee, nicht.
Da lag ich ein bisschen ein bisschen unterm Tisch, muss ich sagen.
Das ist echt auch nochmal geil. Also.
Es trifft ja nicht so wirklich unser äh unser Hauptinteressengebiet äh Osama bin Laden.
Geht ja als der, der, der, der, der, der Mastermind oder was auch immer, der, der, der.
Terrorfirst.
Terror führst, der Terror führst, ähm dem auch der elfte September dann an den ähm dessen Verantwortungsbereich äh gezogen wird.
Zuständige Abteilungsleiter für für die Angriffe.
Genau. Und der, der wurde ja ähm,
in der Nacht auf den zweiten Mai zweitausendelf von einer äh amerikanischen äh amerikanischen äh Spezialeinheit ähm in Pakistan ermordet.
So. Wir haben die haben einige Amerikaner dann noch gefeiert. Äh also die offizielle äh Geschichte ist, die Navy Seals.
Haben der pakistanischen Regierung nicht Bescheid gesagt, haben ihn in seinem pakistanischen Unterschlupf in Abo Tabak,
fangen wollen, ja, die wollten den verhaften,
aber als sie eben die die Schlafzimmertür bei ihm die Schlafzimmertür reingegangen sind, hat dieser alte Mann ähm,
mit einer AK sieben vierzig oder was auf sie geschossen, da mussten sie ihn wegen der versuchten Gegenwehr leider töten und seine Leiche ins Meer werfen.
Das ist die offizielle Geschichte. Und jetzt hat ähm.
War irgendwie, genau, die offizielle Geschichte war auf ihn gekommen sind sie, weil sie nämlich ähm seinen Boden ähm.
Kannten und den verfolgt haben und wer der Boote war, das wussten sie wiederum aus äh Foltervernehmung in äh Guantanamo,
Ja? Das war also die schöne,
die schöne Geschichte der US-Regierung in Guantanamo, Guantanamo, war auch mal endlich für was gut. Da hat uns nämlich jemand gesagt, wer der wer der Boote von Osama bin Laden ist. Ähm,
und den haben wir dann irgendwann gefunden mit unseren mithilfe unserer Nachrichtendienstlichen Aufklärung und dann haben sind wir dem gefolgt und irgendwann wussten wir halt, wo der Osama bin Laden ist und ähm,
und dann haben wir den verhaften wollen, dann mussten wir den leider abknallen, ja? So.
Das ist die offizielle Geschichte, die jetzt seit ein paar Jahren so äh erzählt wird. Irgendwann ist dann auch nochmal derjenige, der den
Navy Seal, der dann Osama auch getötet hat, irgendwie mal in in Auge der Öffentlichkeit geraten. Ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher, ob das äh seine Absicht war oder nicht.
Ja, der hat sich selber geoutet.
Hatte sich selber geortet, ich.
Also soweit wurde es berichtet, ob das.
Panorama, das ist der Teil der Zeitung, den ich nicht lese. Ähm,
aber dann gab es jetzt ja, jetzt wo gerade der BND äh so was von äh also nochmal den Tiefpunkt seiner öffentlichen Warn,
öffentlichen Wahrnehmung noch einmal neu erfindet, ja? Ähm berichtet dann die Bild am Sonntag unter Berufung aus US-Geheimdienst Kreise.
Der BND hat den Osama gefunden. Das war, das ist den US-Geheimdiensten nur mit Hilfe des BNDs gelungen.
Super. Geil.
So und und jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt nämlich der jetzt kommt der Oberwitz, wenn man jetzt, sage ich mal, nicht Bild am Sonntag und Bild liest, sondern,
sich so ein bisschen auch im Bereich der internationalen, investigativen Presse mal informiert, dann ähm ist man vor zwei Wochen.
Über einen Bericht von Samur Hirsch gestolpert, ein relativ bekannter äh US-investigativjournalist mit,
ganz gutem Beruf.
Der dort in einer sehr, sehr langen Darstellung ungefähr folgende äh Geschichte erzählt. Bin Laden war seit zweitausendsechs Gefangener des praktisch
pakistanischen Militärs und des Geheimdienstes des äh Geheimdienstes ISI gewesen.
Davor habe er in den Bergen gelebt. Stammesführer.
Hatten ihnen verraten, an das Pakistanische Militär, nachdem sie Geld erhatten, erhalten hatten.
Sie sie haben ihn benutzt, um die Taliban und in der Region zu beeinflussen und er wäre ein Pfand gewesen, um die US-Regierung bei geeigneter Gelegenheit zu einem Handel zu zwingen.
Außerdem gibt's natürlich entscheidende Zweifel, dass so eine Kill-Mission, also eine diese Tötungsmission ähm.
Ohne Wissen des Pakistanischen Militärs und des Geheimdienst hätte durchgeführt werden können,
Also sagt er, es waren nicht die Boten, die den Aufenthaltsort von Bin Laden verraten haben, sondern am Ende ein Geheimdienstoffizier aus Pakistan?
Der die fünfundzwanzig Millionen US-Dollar einstreichen wollte, die auf Hinweise zu Bin Laden ausgeschrieben waren.
Er habe auch berichtet, dass Bin Laden ein Krüppel sei, was herrscht entsprechend auch Zweifel lässt, ob er sich überhaupt hätte zur Wehr setzen können, wie das Weiße Haus berichtet.
Gibt's also einen sehr langen Artikel. Ähm,
Erschien in der London-Review of Books äh mit dem Titel ähm the killing of Osama bin Laden von ähm und das ist doch jetzt mal sehr interessant.
Schreibt eine lange recherchierte Geschichte, mit der er seinen kompletten Ruf aufs aufs Spiel setzt, wenn sie sich als Unwahr herausstellen sollte.
In der er die offizielle Geschichtsschreibung der USA in Frage stellt.
Und eine Woche oder zwei Wochen später wird uns auf einmal erzählt, na, dann war's halt der BND, der den, der den, der den Hinweis gegeben hat.
Ja? Während Deutschland irgendwie händeringend irgendwas braucht, um äh um die um die den äh.
Dem BND und vor allem seine ähm ausufernde Zusammenarbeit mit der NSA irgendwie zu rechtfertigen, ist das natürlich eine tolle Geschichte.
Und die Amerikaner, naja, denen berichtet jetzt auch kein Zacken aus der Krone, wenn sie die Geschichte nochmal halbwegs umschreiben.
Ich hätte das jetzt diese Osama-Geschichte hätte ich niemals wirklich behandelt, weil ich das ähm ja, ganz.
Da äh kann ich nichts zu sagen, der ist nicht mein Fachgebiet. Aber das ähm,
dass der BND am Ende der der CIA geholfen hat,
Osama bin Laden zu finden und zu töten. Das halte ich für relativ unwahrscheinlich. Das halte ich für eine relativ unwahrscheinliche Geschichte. Denn wenn diese wahr wäre, dann wäre, dann hätten sie uns jetzt sehr viel früher erzählt,
da wären sie richtig stolz drauf gewesen. Das ist also, das ist hier äh das ist äh erbärmlich, das ist ganz schlecht. Ganz schlechte, ganz schlechtes Tennis. Und,
Da kommt noch die nächste Meldung direkt noch mit ins Spiel. Die hat auch irgendwie nicht wirklich bei irgendjemanden verfangen. Auch letzte Woche oder letztes Wochenende.
Cyberangriff auf den Bundestag. Hast du mitbekommen, Tim?
Ich, das habe ich für dich nur so am Rande äh gecheckt, weil ich überhaupt nicht gecheckt habe, also ich habe sie nicht, ich hab's nicht gecheckt.
Ich hab's auch nicht gecheckt, weil's keine keine Informationen dazu gab. Ähm.
Es gab einfach nur, es war einfach nur so.
Angriff auf das interne Datennetz des Bundestages in noch nie da gewesener Härte.
Es hat gesalbert.
Dass interne Datennetz des Bundestags, ob irgendwelche hochsensible Informationen betroffen ist, ist unklar.
Das Internet Datennetz des Bundestags wurde attackiert.
Das aber keine Sorge, das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik sitzt schon im Zug.
Und äh wird das jetzt untersuchen. Details kann man aber nicht sagen,
Die Angriffe von außen gehen weiter, sagte dann der Vorsitzende der IT-Kommunik, die Vorsitzende der IT-Kommission und Vizepräsidentin des Bundestags Petra Pau, der DPA,
Seit Dienstag sei sie darüber informiert,
es habe einen Angriff von außen gegeben, die Unbekannten hätten dabei auch versucht, eine Software einzuschleusen, die ein weiteres Eindringen ermöglichen sollte und und um damit Computer zu infizieren.
Einen solchen Angriff über mehrere Tage hat es noch nicht gegeben. Also.
Es ist halt sehr interessant. Was ist jetzt was ist jetzt wirklich ein Angriff, ne? Also wenn du einen Computer mit dem Internet verbindest mit einer öffentlichen IP-Adresse, dann prasselt da,
eine ganze Menge drauf ein,
wenn du so ein so ein Webserver einfach mal anschaltest und einfach nur in die Loks guckst, dann kommen halt die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Scanner, irgendwelche Scans vorbei und versuchen da alle möglichen Mist anzugreifen. Das ist einfach normal. Das heißt, angegriffen,
mit einer mit einer mit einer plumpen Definition wird jeder Rechner im Internet andauernd,
Wohlgemerkt Rechner, die jetzt so normal ans Internet gestöpselt sind, die also eine V4-Adresse haben und ähm.
Ja, das ist kein, das ist kein, das ist kein Vorfall, sondern das ist einfach ein, ein Normalzustand. Man ist einfach permanent irgendwelchen Attacken,
ausgesetzt, weil einfach permanent das ganze Netz gescannt wird, also das normale V4-Netz zum Beispiel, äh zumindest. Und ähm jetzt mit den
mit dem neuen Adressraum werden die Karten nochmal ein bisschen neu äh gemischt, aber es ist halt nichts Außergewöhnliches und da fahren jetzt nicht unbedingt schwarze Autos vor, nur wenn da mal irgendwo ein,
Ein Abfühlen von außen stattfindet.
Das ist Grundrauschen. Man kann das Internet Grundrauschen nennen und.
Jetzt gehe ich mal natürlich davon aus, dass dass das jetzt nicht der Fall ist, ja das also das hätten sie ja schon irgendwie festgestellt. Angriffe auf das interne Netzt, ja also okay
nur sie sagen halt nicht, ob jemand drin war oder nicht. Es gibt einfach keine Informationen dazu. Dann wurde in einer in einer späteren Meldung war dann die Rede von einem die Nyil of Serviceangriff.
Ähm.
Keiner wisse, wer hinter diesem Dinal of Service angesteckt. Ist aber schon wieder was ganz anderes, als jetzt ein Trojaner, ja. Also es gibt einfach keine keine,
Keine Information über diesen, über diesen Cyber-Angriff und auch da wieder, ich meine, ey, wenn wir grade davon reden, dieses etwas unsinnige IT-Sicherheitsgesetz
auf die Bahn zu bringen, wenn heute dieser IT-Sicherheitsgipfel stattfindet, in dem dann Thomas de Maizire um äh
beklagt, dass es eine digitale Sorglosigkeit gäbe und dass ja alles alles noch viel, viel schlimmer ist.
Ähm da fragt man sich auch, was so eine so eine Meldung überhaupt soll?
Tja, das fragt man sich. Ich freue mich das auch. Wer hat denn diese Meldung überhaupt herausgegeben?
Es scheint die Petra Paul gewesen zu sein.
Warum macht die denn das?
Verstehe ich auch nicht. Wobei im Moment, sie hat sich nur dazu geäußert, wer äh wer es jetzt wirklich ähm.
Also nur mal, also okay,
IT-Spezialisten des Parlaments war schon vor mehreren Tagen aufgefallen, dass unbekannte versuchen in das interne Netz des Bundestages einzudringen. Natürlich den ganzen Tag,
Also,
Natürlich, was denkst du denn, da wird den ganzen Tag angegriffen, den es ja wohl völlig klar. Also, ich meine, das Ding, die haben keine keine ähm keine ruhige Minute, deswegen finde ich's auch interessant, wenn sie ja immer nur so von Versuch reden, ja.
Offenbar wollten, sich Hacker Zugriff auf Informationen verschaffen. Ja sicher, Hacker hacken und zwar den ganzen Tag. So weil die Welt äh die Sonne irgendwo immer auf diesem Planeten leuchtet, wo gerade
Hacker schlafen, aber da wo sie nicht hinleuchtet, ne, da sind die Hacker ja dann wach und dann haken sie. Und natürlich greifen sie irgendwie Infrastruktur des des Bundestags an. Also ich
verstehe überhaupt nicht, was das soll, was wo da jetzt der der Neuigkeits äh,
Wert dieser Meldung ist und insofern glaube ich, das ist echt einfach nur halt,
Flort, ja? Wir kriegen auch keine Information. Ist einfach nur ja, hier wir werden hier schrecklich angegriffen. Kann ich auch sagen. Kann ich sagen, meine Server im Internettipp, die sind gerade,
an Angriffen ausgesetzt.
Ja, ich kriege auch.
Und ich habe keine Ahnung, von wem die sind.
Ja, aber ich kann dir sicher sagen, dass keine es keine Daten äh herausgegeben wurden. Ja, das ist also schon mal total äh klar,
Finde ich auch eine schöne Feststellung, ja? Also sie haben sie wissen nicht genau, was passiert. Sie wissen nicht genau, wer es ist. Sie sind noch dabei, sich das alles anzuschauen. Es überwältigt sie, weil es auf einmal unheimlich krass und äh groß ist,
Aber sie wissen total sicher, dass auf gar keinen Fall äh Daten äh herausgegeben wurden, weil sie haben wahrscheinlich nochmal nachgeschaut und zwar noch alle da.
Mal so ein bisschen so.
Und sie reden dann halt auch irgendwie von von den plötzlich, ja? Also unklar, es gibt halt keine Informationen, deswegen können wir nur spekulieren und ähm ja, was willst du dazu noch sagen?
Weiß ich auch nicht, aber das ist schon so noch ein bisschen für so eine Teilöffentlichkeit, die eben,
Einbruch und und und die Folgen immer noch so ein bisschen mit leergeräumte Regale und umgestürzte äh Mobiliar äh assoziiert, ja. Dass das halt einfach in in der digitalen, in Digitalen,
so nicht aussieht und so nicht funktioniert, das ist einfach noch nicht verinnerlicht worden.
Du, Tim, das kann auch sehr gut sein, dass da irgendwie grade richtig krasse Angriffe stattfinden. Ich würde ja schon irgendwie vermuten und hoffen, dass diese ähm, dass die,
ähm Bundestags IT da irgendwie halbwegs ein bisschen ähm kompetent ist in der Erkennung und Abwehr von Angriffen, das kann ja durchaus sein,
Das kann, kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, aber,
Was ich immer äh äh versuche zu betonen, der Angriff, den du entdeckt hast, das ist der, in der Regel erfolgloser. Ja, weil den hast du ja entdeckt.
Mehr Sorgen musst du über das machen, was du nicht entdeckt hast. Aber okay, wir kriegen keine Information, deswegen können wir da jetzt auch nichts zu sagen. Ich weiß nicht, ähm auf welchem Niveau deren äh Detektions-Cup äh Fähigkeiten liegen,
weiß noch nicht mal, welche Art von Angriff äh hier äh festgestellt werden soll, weil sowohl von einem Trojaner als von einem Service als auch von einem
Einbruch, der aber keine Informationen bekommen hat die Rede ist, weiß der Geier.
Irgendwas ist vielleicht passiert. Das ist im Prinzip die Aussage.
Irgendwas ist vielleicht passiert, Cyber Cyber und äh Osama Billan haben wir auch gefunden. So und jetzt gehen sie bitte weiter. Hier gibt es nix zu sehen. Und dass uns gerade irgendein durchgeknallter Österreicher verklagt, äh dit äh warten wir mal ab.
Jetzt machen wir erstmal Vorratsdatenspeicherung. So sieht's, ja.
Genau. Oh.
Kommen wir zu den, kommen wir zu den Kurzmeldungen. Ähm gab's eine ganz interessante Meldung, dass jetzt Mobilfunkanbieter darüber nachdenken. Sie könnten doch mal ähm Werbung blockieren.
Und zwar eine mit der israelischen Firma Schein eingehen, die nämlich Werbeblocker für äh für mobil
für Netzwerke äh anbietet. Also letztendlich ein Proxi oder eine Lösung, die halt vernünftig dafür sorgt, dass diese Werbung nicht mehr kommt. Sie sagen, sie wollen Werbung in Webseiten und Apps blockieren,
sogenannte Infeed-Anzeigen, wie sie etwa bei Twitter oder Facebook zum Einsatz kommen, jedoch aussparen. Dass sie die aussparen liegt daran, dass sie die nicht filtern können,
Ja, das ist eine, das ist nicht irgendwie eine Großzügigkeit, dass sie das nicht machen, sondern das ist, dass sie's technisch nicht hinkriegen, weil die Werbung da eben von Facebook,
und genauso aussieht wie jeder andere Status auch und sieht deswegen nicht filtern können. Werbung in Webseiten oder Apps oder Apps blockierst du.
In der Regel relativ einfach, indem du diese ganzen,
dir bekannten Server von Werbeetzen einfach nicht ansteuern lässt, indem du die Verbindung dahin nicht zulässt oder indem du ganz einfach die DNS äh Auflösung einfach schon schon platzen lässt.
Oder indem du eben, wie es sich gehört, einen Werbeblocker auf deinem
Computerhass. So gibt's aber bei dem Mobiltelefon nicht so wirklich als Plug-ins, weil die Standard Browser von Mobiltelefonen nicht plaque äh Plug-in-fähig sind. Da muss man sich irgendwie so eine App runterladen, gibt's dann auch wieder, ne? Werbeblockierter Browser oder so.
So, jetzt sagen die, ja, das wäre doch eine tolle Sache, wenn wir Werbung blockieren, denn einerseits hätten wir dadurch eine,
durchaus signifikante Bandbreitenreduktion.
Das heißt, unsere Mobiltelefon und unsere Mobilfunknetze sind weniger stark belastet. Und es ist durchaus eine Dienstleistung am Kunden.
Der Kunde wird nicht mehr mit der, mit der Scheißwerbung genervt. Ist doch eine Win-win-Situation. Ja, wir wir nehmen einfach den Mist äh aus, aus, aus, aus unseren Datennetzen raus und für den Kunden wird das, wird das Internet angenehmer.
Ähm gleichzeitig vergessen sie aber natürlich, dass man,
genau dieses Ergebnis eben mit ein paar DNS Manipulation Manipulationen heute schon relativ einfach hinkriegt, ja? Nimmst du diese ganzen Werbenetzwerke ähm und sagst, okay,
einfach äh diese diese Namen einfach nicht auflösen, falsche IP zurückgeben oder so, ne? Ähm oder diese IPs oder IP-Blöcke nicht ruhten, kann man viel machen.
Aber was hier natürlich in Wirklichkeit machen wollen, ist, dass wie jeder andere Werbeblocker auch seine seine ähm seine Dienstleistung, seine kostenlose Dienstleistung am Kunden monetarisiert, nämlich indem er.
Die blockierten Werbeanbieter damit erpresst und sagt, okay, zahlt mal. Ihr nutzt bei uns Bandbreite, dann zahlt doch mal.
Es ist eine Netzneutralitätsverletzung, hier wieder eine, wo man sagt, okay, da kann der Kunde doch nun wirklich nichts gegen haben,
können wir dem noch verkaufen, das können wir noch als Feature anbieten. Da freut er sich drüber. Und das heißt, wir haben hier natürlich wieder ein klares Gewinninteresse und ein klares Erpressungsinteresse,
Werbung zu blockieren,
Das ist das, das ist das die wichtige Sache, die man, die man hier sagen muss, Werbung zu blockieren gehört auf den Client und nicht ins Netz.
Du sollst als Kunde für dich entscheiden können, ob du ähm ob du einen Werbeblocker haben willst oder nicht,
Den kannst du dann auf deinem kleinen installieren oder nicht. Und dann kannst du dir Werbung angucken oder nicht.
Also das ist wirklich eine eine haarsträubende Geschichte. Ich meine, was du äh ansprichst, ist äh sind so Unternehmen wie AdBlock äh Plus,
Unternehmen übrigens, ja, die mit so einem
ähm Werbeblogger, Plug-in ja relativ erfolgreich sind. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das erfolgreichste Plug-in sind, aber sie sind wohl schon ziemlich äh verbreitet. Und die haben halt im Prinzip dieses Geschäftsmodell der der ja der freien Erpressung äh quasi neu definiert.
So eine moderne Wegelage eingeführt und so nach dem Motto na ja wir nehmen jetzt überall erstmal die Werbung raus, weil das ist ja gut für die Menschen.
Wir tun ja was Gutes, aber dann hintenrum,
die quasi freigewordenen Slots wieder verkauft an äh Unternehmen, die ja bestimmten Standards dann entsprechen müssen, keine Ahnung, es
blind nicht, keine Ahnung, aber im Wesentlichen ist so die äh die Kategorie halt äh wenn wir dafür Geld bekommen, dann schalten wir das auch wieder frei
ja, wo man sich natürlich auch wiederum fragt, okay, was ist dann sozusagen jetzt der Gewinn für den Nutzer dieses Plug-ins, wenn man eigentlich Werbung weghaben will, aber jetzt kommt sie dann doch wieder, nur dass sie eben von jemand anders nochmal woanders bezahlt wurde,
Das ist ähm finde ich schon mal extrem fragwürdig. Und ähm das ist übrigens auch insofern extrem fragwürdig.
Als dass das auch so ein bisschen auch über Werbung hinausgeht, weil äh diese AdBlock
Plattformen sozusagen nochmal so eigene Netze werden, ja, die quasi dort Zugang und Freischaltung von Diensten verkaufen. Das geht ja, das kann ja auch weit über Werbung hinaus gehen,
installiert man sich da so ein Party, Internetfilter, über dessen Funktion man überhaupt gar keine,
keinen Einfluss hat, ja? Und wo man dann irgendeine äh Firma darüber entscheiden lässt, was denn noch zu einem durchkommt,
und das muss, wie gesagt, nicht nur
Werbung sein. Das können jede Form von Like Button sein, äh jegliches, standardisiertes äh äh Element, was in irgendeiner Form entbettet wird, in in Webseiten, da greift das Ding halt irgendwie rein. Auf diesem Level,
von Netzbetreibern finde ich das jetzt nochmal super perfide,
Also nochmal auf so einem ganz anderen Level, weil das ist ja auch nichts, was also ich meine dieses AdBlock-Plugin, kann man natürlich sagen, also AdBlockplus, wohlgemerkt, es gibt da immer diese Verwirrung. Es gibt,
in meinen Augen nach wie vor ein vertretbares Stück Software ist. Es gibt AdBlockplus, was das,
keiner Hinsicht äh erfüllt diese Anforderung. Und ähm das installiere ich mir oder ich installiere es mir nicht.
Das heißt, ich habe da noch die Wahl. Und wenn ich die Wahl getroffen habe, ist zu installieren, dann kann man auch sagen, okay, ich wusste vielleicht nicht Bescheid, aber immerhin selber Schuld, ne?
Beim Netz Provider ist das natürlich nicht ganz so einfach. Schon gar nicht, wenn irgendwie alle dasselbe Spiel spielen,
Hatte das jetzt übrigens gerade selber, wir sind irgendwie gerade so ein bisschen in der Softwareentwicklung und so mit Image, und eigenes Cashing testen und so, ne? Und dann
saß ich irgendwo so im Kaffee und das WLAN taugte nichts und dann habe ich hier irgendwie Tessering gemacht.
Also mein Internet über meinen Mobilfunkbetreiber im ruhigen hier in England äh bezogen und ähm,
starte auf diese URLs, die ich da eigentlich grade analysieren wollte, also ne, so ein bisschen mal so Softwareentwicklung, mal gucken, was passiert denn da eigentlich und bekam halt vollkommen aufs gutes Zeug irgendwie auf einmal vor die Nase,
wo ich dann merkte
das ich gar nicht in der Lage war, unser Imageresing zu debacken, weil das Mobilfunknetz für mich ein Image Receing nochmal vorgenommen hat. Das heißt, meine eigene Webseite, ja, wo ich grade versuche, ein Feature einzubauen, genau dieses Feature kommt nicht zu mir durch,
weil der Mobilfunkbetreiber der Meinung ist, er müsste jetzt da irgendwie in meinen Bildern irgendwie rum vorwerfen. Geile Nummer.
Weil du kein HTTPS hast.
Weil ich keiner hatte die PSV. Was ich liebend gerne hätte, ja, da kannst du jetzt viel äh lachen, ja.
Nein, ich ich wollte dich nur ärgern.
Gerne, gerne schalte ich mir das morgen frei, aber auch das ist übrigens nicht so einfach. Also einerseits
will sie nicht in Details der Installation der Mittelebene gehen, da gibt's sicherlich eigenes eigene Versäumnisse, aber ist auch nicht so äh ohne Weiteres möglich heutzutage Podcast mal eben auf HTPS umzustellen.
Ähm aber nichtsdestotrotz, das das will ich auch tun und äh es gibt noch genug Webseiten, die ähm harte TBO sind, die ist ja jetzt hier nicht die Frage, ja,
Die eigentliche Frage ist, mit welchem Recht,
greift eigentlich jetzt hier einen Provider ein. Jetzt kommen sie natürlich erstmal mit diesem Argument, mit na ja, Bandbreitenreduktion und so weiter, dann verbrauchst du nicht so viel Daten, wir machen die Bilder klein. Was übrigens nicht wollte, ja, ich habe
zwei Stunden lang draufgestarrt, mich gefragt, warum dieses Bild so scheiße aussieht, bis ich dann irgendwie geschnallt habe, das ist der Mobilfunk Provider ist, der mir mein Image Recycling irgendwie verkackt, ja? Und ich wunderte mich die ganze Zeit, warum die Software nicht funktioniert,
aber jetzt äh um beim Thema zu bleiben, hier sind ja dann diese Überlegungen mit, na ja, wir nehmen jetzt mal die Werbung raus. Ist ja nicht so, weil sie irgendwie ihre Kunden so geil finden.
Ja, so nach dem Motto, unsere Kunden, die leiden alle so unter Werbung und so, das geht ja gar nicht, ja.
Das ist sehr belustigend, der der Gedanke, dass das auch nur einer dieser ähm
äh in dem Unternehmen beschäftigt und ist äh auf so eine Idee kommen würde, ja? Mitnichten ist es so, sondern man will eigentlich auch hier wieder moderne Wegelagerei, ich benutze dieses Wort sehr gerne, weil es an meiner äh äh meiner Meinung nach an der Stelle wirklich extrem gut passt
ja? Du bist einfach in so einem Waldstück der Herr.
Und da kommen dann irgendwelche Dahergelaufenen mit ihrer Kutsche an und das wird dann einfach erst mal äh angehalten. Und äh,
ab jetzt definieren wir die Regeln hier für die nächsten paar Meter. Und im nächsten Wald schon wieder, ja, so hast du dann vielleicht auch so eine ganze Cascade von Mobilfunk äh Providern, wo das dann immer so hin und her geht oder nicht nur einen Mobilfunk Provider. Ich meine, heute sind es Mobilfunkprovider, Ausrede der Bandbreitenbegrenzung
Morgen sind's alle Prowalter, die das machen. Das heißt, überall soll die ganze Zeit in deinen Datenstrom reingegriffen werden,
Dinge wollten manipuliert werden, ohne dass du darüber in Kenntnis gesetzt wirst oder auch du, dass du das möchtest. Unter Gefährdung der ähm,
Betriebssicherheit sozusagen auch des Systems. Weil wenn das nicht ausgeliefert wird, was du auslieferst, dann bist du ja zwangsläufig du irgendwie auch schuldig.
Und ich frage mich halt, um das jetzt mal wieder auf eine politische Diskussion zurückzubringen,
Inwiefern in unser schönes Grundrecht auf Gewährleistungen äh der äh wie heißt es so schön, die Integrität,
Unsere Informationstechnischen Systeme äh dort nicht aufgreift, weil wer sagt denn, dass das nur greifen muss ähm sozusagen onside, da wo der Computer ist, sondern ob man das nicht auch einfach mal so interpretieren kann
dass eben diese äh Integrität auch gewährleistet werden muss in seinem Betrieb,
Ja, also wie kann es sein, dass mir ein Netzbetreiber.
Äh meine Datenströme manipuliert, kurz gesagt. Und ähm das halte ich auf jeden Fall für eine wertvolle Debatte und das, was jetzt hier angestrebt wird, das ist auf jeden Fall.
Ähm unlauter.
Das ist ziemlich unlauter, ja. Das ist ziemlich es zeigt auch so dieses dieses Perfide, ne, weil ich meine, wenn die damit durch, also stellen wir uns mal vor, sie bieten das an.
Ja? Sagen, ey, nicht nur das schnellste Netz, sondern auch das werbefreiste Netz, dann äh dann wirst du noch weniger Leute finden, die sagen, nee, nee, wir wollen die Werbung zurück haben, ne?
Ja, also.
Aber klar, es ist ja, es spielt ja, es spielt ja noch was da rein, ja? Wenn sie sagen, okay, die Facebook-Inline-Sachen kriegen wir nicht weg, die Twitter-Inline-Sachen kriegen wir nicht weg.
Wenn es geht natürlich auch da wieder darum, äh Kugel anzupissen, weil das kriegst du weg,
da und so, die kriegst du halt rausgefiltert. Und ähm,
Da wollen sie sich natürlich auch wieder mit äh also die wollen da in in so viele, also das das ist es ist so eine.
Also so perfide und gleichzeitig so genial könnte fast von mir sein, weil die ähm,
die Idee, dass du diese diese ganze Netzneutralitätsdebatte jetzt so zu spinnen.
Echt Hut ab. Das ist ein das ist echt ein ein guter Spin, den die in die Nummer reinbringen können. Und,
Det machen sie jetzt auch. Und ich bin mal, also ich hoffe natürlich, dass sie auch damit wieder nicht durchkommt, ne? Aber wir wir werden halt,
sie offenbaren, damit natürlich auch wieder, dass es ihnen selbstverständlich nur.
Um diese Wegelagerei geht, wie immer, wenn sie mit irgendwas kommen, was die Netzneutralität verlässt, verletzt, denn,
Netzneutralität heißt einfach nur, keine Wegelagerei und genau das wollen sie und deswegen ist es so, ja, aber ähm.
Wir werden auch dieses Mal wieder natürlich eine entsprechende Aufklärungsarbeit leisten müssen, um wieder zu erklären, warum das scheiße ist, um wieder zu erklären, ähm,
warum man sich dagegen wehren muss. Und mit mit Internet dot org und äh Werbeblocken auf Mobilfunknetz ebene ähm haben wir jetzt schon zwei,
ähm zwei ganz wirkmächtige PR-Gegner. Ähm,
Dot org ist natürlich auch hoffentlich grade auf dem Weg zur zur Bauchlandung. Die IFF hat sich da jetzt auch nochmal ähm.
Zu geäußert und der der wahrgenommene Ruf dieser Initiative in der Öffentlichkeit ist, glaube ich, ähm relativ schlecht
und das ist auch gut so und hoffentlich kriegen wir das bei dieser Werbesache auch hin und hoffentlich kriegen wir vielleicht irgendwann mal eine gesetzliche verankerte Netzneutralität äh wie andere zivilisierte ähm,
Nationen dieser Welt auch.
Internet dot org, das zweifelhafte Projekt von äh Facebook, was.
Noch, sonst irgendwas.
Ja. Äh wir hatten da noch irgendwas übersprungen.
Wir hatten was übersprungen, das habe ich aber jetzt rausgenommen.
Ah, Ball war unwichtig. Das heißt, wir.
Das war nur eine Kurzmeldung. Und wir haben schon so viele Kurzmeldungen. Die Sendung ist schon wieder so lang, dass es äh ich kann mir jetzt nicht noch eine eine Kurzmeldung trauen. Oder sollen wir noch eine Kurzmeldung machen?
Äh da ich jetzt schon gar nicht mehr weiß und erinnere, was die Kurzmeldung war, musst du das jetzt mal selber äh entscheiden. Ich äh gut, tada.
Nein, lass mal weg. Wir lassen mal jetzt weg. Wir wir halten.
Lang genug, wir haben schon wieder fast zwei Stunden hier voll irgendwie.
Genau, wir halten das, wir wir halten das in nee, anderthalb. Wir ähm vorenthalten das jetzt einfach mal. Wir können ja auch mal unsere Geheimnisse haben. Warum sollen wir eigentlich immer alles transparent machen? Ja.
Ja. Gute Frage.
Sehe ich überhaupt nicht ein.
Wir machen mal eine geheime Ausgabe von Lokbuchen Netzpolitik.
Machen wir doch schon andauer.
Da erzählen wir nix. Nüscht, nüscht, sagen wir.
Nix.
Einfach eine Stunde Schweigen und dementieren.
Und rumreden und Ausreden, Ausschöpfen und so und alles alles schönreden. Das können wir auch mal.
Machen wir. Wenn uns die Scheiße mal wirklich bis zum Hals steht.
Gar keinen Humor mehr entwickelt bekommen.
Ich möchte an dieser Stelle noch herzlich dem Matze und dem Luca danken und spielen wir am Ende Musik ein, haben wir einen haben wir heute einen musikalischen Gast?
Ja, ja. Ich denke schon, ja, da passt was.
Dann wünsche ich viel Freude äh mit mit der Musik.
Ja, ich auch. Bis bald.